bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous
alors le conseil de l'europe critique à
son tour l'article 24 de la loi sécurité
globale votre réaction
pareil je vais peut-être vous surprendre
mais dans la loi sécurité globale pour
ma part c'est pas l'article 24 qui
m'inquiète le plus sûr enfin compte les
autres articles qui parlent de du
continuum de sécurité et qui va
permettre à l'état de se désengager de
sa fonction régalienne de sécurité est
en réalité l'article 24 quelque part
focalise les médias focalisent l'opinion
publique mais en réalité si on était un
peu plus observateurs on ferait bien de
s'inquiéter de voir la dérive de l'état
qui se désengage de sa mission de
sécurité
on profite des polices municipales voire
de ddd compagnie de sécurité des
sociétés de sécurité privées vous voyez
quoi donc c'est pas le si bien sûr
l'article 24 créé beaucoup d'émotion
beaucoup de débats en réalité le fond de
cette loi va être beaucoup plus lourd de
conséquence compte se l'imaginent
mais sur l'aspect liberticide que
dénoncent plusieurs ong concernant
l'article le 24 votre avis là-dessus on
a vu quelque part comme je viens de vous
le dire quelque part pour moi ce n'est
pas fondamental que quelque part je
comprends tout à fait c'est tout à fait
légitime que la presse qui suit à son
travail puisse prendre des photos lors
de manifestations etc
quelque part ça ne me dérange pas
vraiment est ce que beaucoup plus grave
c'est sur les réseaux sociaux lorsque
des personnes des individus se
permettent de mettre des coordonnées les
adresses les visages des photos de
policiers ce qui peut avoir de lourdes
conséquences dans leur vie dans leur vie
de tous les jours
ces boutons plus si vous voulez c'est
d'autant plus dommageable à l'égard de
l'institution policière
c'est que l'institution policière paye
aujourd'hui très lourdement le mouvement
de gilet jaune alors qu'enfin compte
elle avait fait preuve d'une très grande
loyauté envers le ce qui est son
obligation d'ailleurs un a lâché 3 une
très grande loyauté à l'égard d'un
gouvernement qui n'avait pas voulu
traiter le problème politiquement et qui
avait préféré aller à l'affrontement
et aujourd'hui c'est la police dans sa
dans son lien avec la population qui est
en train de le payer très cher est-ce
que c'est toujours le cas par exemple
avec la loi sécurité globale en ce
samedi là qui se succèdent des scènes
immobilisations écoutez je pense qu'il
est durant encore des exactions commises
à l'occasion de ces deux de ces
manifestations puisque le pli semble
avoir été pris on voit bien que les
black blocks n'hésite pas à ces
messieurs dans ces manifestations pour
pour faire des pour commettre d'étape
des solutions donc je pense que le cycle
on a enclenché avec les gilet jaune il
ya plus d'un an un cycle infernal
parce qu'on n'a pas voulu régler
politiquement il est aujourd'hui ça nous
revient en boomerang
demain il ya une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation contre la loi sécurité
globale qui est attendu à quoi faut-il
s'attendre à de nouvelles violences ou
alors les forces de l'ordre vont gérer
comme la semaine passée d'ailleurs ça
s'est magnifiquement bien passé mais
pour une raison très simple c'est qu'il
y avait 3000 policiers et cinq mille
manifestants
donc là le rapport de force était en
faveur de la police et sa saison très
très bien passé
ils ont pu se permettre de faire des
interpellations j'allais dire non tant
préventives et rue du moins des
incursions rapide de nombreuses attaques
de nombreuses incursions au sein même du
cortège qui a pu éviter toutes les ai
toutes les dégradations
ce matin donc si demain on se retrouve
dans la même configuration je pense
qu'on aura une manifestation tout aussi
apaisée ce matin gérald darmanin il a
reçu les syndicats des forces de l'ordre
il ya un bout de la sécurité qui
s'annonce
ce que d'abord vous considérez que ce
boulot d'insécurité c'est une volte face
de la part à des autorités après les
propos d' emmanuel macron je crois que
les propos de mâcon et aimer
incendiaires je crois que je dis vous
savez que là on avait déjà eu le cas
avec le précédent ministre de
l'intérieur
là c'est le président de la république
qui ne s'est pas rendu compte de la
portée de ses paroles au sein de
l'institution policière
j'ai bien peur que le divorce soit
totalement consommée et le fait de créer
un beau la sécurité ou de permettre aux
policiers d'avoir la gratuité du
transport
alors que ça existe déjà par exemple à
la préfecture de police tous les
foncières de police sont la gratuité des
transports depuis des décennies donc je
n'ai pas l'impression que c'est ça qui
va calmer le la colère des policiers
enfin compte la société française vis de
véritables convulsions personne ne s'en
rendre compte en fin de compte on a une
une france qui a la fièvre est vrai en
train de prendre la température des
ambulanciers donc et et de critiquer les
ambulanciers je pense que le débat
mériterait beaucoup plus de hauteur une
prise de conscience beaucoup plus
importante de la réalité de la société
française aujourd'hui est la rencontre
de ce matin avec les syndicats à beauvau
avec les syndicats de la défense de
l'ordre
j'ai peur a encore une fois c'est que on
ne traite pas du fond des problèmes
c'est à dire de pourquoi pourquoi est ce
que la société française est devenue
aussi violente pourquoi est-ce qui a
autant de la une telle explosion de la
délinquance pourquoi est ce que l'on à
des des quartiers où la police mais
depuis les ché et qu'on tombe dans le
piège de revendications corporatistes
alors chez c'est ça ma grande peur et la
colère des policiers par exemple la
reine et les policiers ont manifesté
dans la préfecture mais aussi aux abords
du domicile de la mère pour dénoncer
leurs conditions de travail la mère de
ré nathalie appéré qui a dénoncé des
méthodes d'intimidation inadmissible on
est obligé d'en arriver là que des
conspirations et elle mais j'ai envie de
vous dire que moi je suis à la retraite
donc je suis un peu de liberté et les
libérer de mon obligation de mon devoir
de réserve
ça fait 30 ans que l'on dit que la
société française est un peu en
déliquescence
on n'a pas voulu prendre en compte le
fait que la police et 1
c'est un curseur d'appréciation de la
société e
je crois que c'est c'est camus dans les
justes qui dit je fais le policier est
au centre des choses et on ne sait pas
bien rendu compte par nos appels répétés
en dix ans la société va mal on ne l'a
pas pris en considération et aujourd'hui
et bien je vous dis ce sont les
ambulanciers qui c'est pas possible on y
prend pour cible on peut plus s'en
sortir
merci beaucoup à vous maurice signolet
je rappelle que vous êtes commissaire
divisionnaire honoraire merci